je crois qu'on a souffert au cours de
cette crise d'un défaut d'acculturation
scientifique de la population française
autrement dit quand on devait expliquer
que pour pouvoir tester un traitement
il fallait faire ce qu'on appelle les
bras qui permettent d'expérimenter la
validité d'un traitement que ça prenait
des semaines et des semaines on était
confronté à des gens sur des plateaux de
télévision ou même à des citoyens qui
vous interroger dans vos déplacements
quand on pouvait encore se dépasser qui
vous disais mais pourquoi c'est pas oui
ou non
3 c'est pas blanc ou noir et pourquoi ce
n'est pas tout de suite comment vous
vous qui êtes recensé être l'élite
politique médicale de décideurs vous
êtes incapable de nous dire si c'est
maintenant tout de suite et expliqué
comparé d'hypothèses que ces hypothèses
doivent être soumises doivent être
testés qu'ensuite il faut qu'ils aient
de la convergence pour que plusieurs
bras expérimentaux sur les médicaments
convergent pour donner la même réponse
et que c'est à partir de là qu'on
donnera une réponse définitive
ça a été très difficile et ça marque
aussi le rapport au temps de notre
société
aujourd'hui on veut que d'un claquement
de doigts toutes les réponses à toutes
les questions qu'on se pose soit
apporter immédiatement et dès que vous
aller sur un plateau de télévision quand
vous êtes un rabbin un décideur
politique pour dire c'est plus compliqué
que ça réfléchissons prenons le temps on
vous accuse d'atermoyer on vous dit que
vous n'allez pas assez vite et si on va
en suivant le fil de cette crise plus
loin notamment au moment du décompte
final
rappelons-nous chacun les interventions
qui voulait ouvrir les parcs et jardins
tout de suite alors qu' il y avait des
doutes des incertitudes sur le fait que
ça pouvait être bénéfique dans un moment
de déconfinement voilà je voulais
terminer en disant qu'il y avait sans
doute aussi ces deux sujets là qu'il
fallait prendre en compte mais qu'en
aucun cas le gouvernement
je crois n'avait manqué ni deux ni de
célérité ni de concentration ni
d'attention au moment de rentrer dans
cette pandémie